what I what I learned most from Carnegie
was the camaraderie of company you know
my dad was very close to my class and
and we created some some pretty
wonderful pieces in that wonderful old
cinder block studio theatre which we all
loved because it it really felt like a
very free playground my time at Carnegie
Mellon the people that I met the network
that was formed the challenges I had
their I mean it was all part of what got
me to New York and I feel like it was an
absolutely indispensable part of my
education and part of my career now the
absolute foundation this year with with
gentleman's guide I mean I just saw that
and thought it is so clever it's like
why I got on Peter in the starcatcher
because it uses your imagination it's
not you know it's not a 20 million
dollars set it's you know strings that
make houses and steps and chips and
waves and I mean I love that kind of
stuff so I think that's the exciting
part of what theater does part of being
a freshman is they make you take all the
design courses as well so if you're not
just in acting you're like you're you're
learning about scenic design and
costumes and I remember they asked me to
him skirts for the production of romeo
juliet and i was like i don't know how
to use a sewing machine and they're like
here's so she hears this fabric I'm like
like shoving through the remember that
and I remember her doing just crazy
wonderful things I actually loved my
time occurring email